You'd think you walk around remembering all
the hotties, but in fact?
What you really remember are the uggos.
[[MUSIC]]
Hey peeps, Trace here for DNews.
When your brain sees a face, what does it
do?
It first has to notice it's looking at a face,
using the bits of a face and putting them
together it attempts to recognize it and gauge
its level of attractiveness.
From there we decide if we want to remember
that face or not -- all in a split second.
Most people would agree, Angelina Jolie has
an attractive face.
She has evenly spaced, large eyes; full lips
and her features are properly sized and placed
on her face in a generally symmetrical way.
Obviously, attractive faces are great // *smile*
// but science has unexpectedly revealed our
brains remember imperfect faces BETTER than
the beautiful ones.
The average symmetrical, attractive, face
is just ... boring to our brain.
Whereas one we might consider an "ugly" face
-- which really means asymmetrical with imperfections
-- is easily remembered!
Something about it is novel and interesting!
There's something called the Von Restorff
Effect, which basically says our brains are
better at recalling unusual things, rather
than ordinary things.
A study in the American Journal of Psychology
from 1997 found distinctive faces tend to
be more easily recognized.
If your friend has a scar or a mole or a misshapen
eye, like poor Sloth from the Goonies -- then
you'll immediately recall who he is -- more
so than your twin friends -- who could be
hard to tell apart.
Another part of this, is task switching.
We've talked before about the brain's inability
to multitask.
When you're in conversation and someone you
recognize, but just can't QUITE place walks
by, what happens?
You stop talking.
Your brain can't search its face library and
talk at the same time.
A study in PlosONE from 2003, found attractive
faces tend to mess up this task-switching
too.
When you try to sneak a look at an attractive
guy in class, the brain turns off active listening
in order to process the attractive face.
A new study published in the journal Neuropsychologia
found similar results to the first, but measured
both recognition AND attractiveness.
The researchers showed attractive faces to
participants and asked them to memorize them.
Later they were asked to identify which faces
they'd seen before.
Like in the first study, recognition got all
wonky when both faces were similar regardless
if they were attractive.
But, these new results reveal our brains are
finding uniqueness more memorable!
An imperfect face is more likely to contain
a misshapen or out of line part.
A certain kind of nose, eye or mouth will
set off something in our brain that serves
as a cue to help remember that face later.
Though, perhaps if you're pretty and have
a beauty mark like Cindy Crawford, or a piercing
or a tattoo you now are more novel and easier
to remember.
Science needs to look into that next.
Funnily enough, there were a lot of false
positives in the study.
When people saw attractive people, they were
more likely to say they'd seen that face before.
Simply put, we want to roll with the hotties.
Do you think you remember ugly faces or attractive
ones more?
There's a comment box down below the video
for a reason.
Why not subscribe, and tell us what you think?
Thanks for watching DNews!